all right well welcome back to the
podcast i'm really pleased to say that
i'm joined today by a couple of my
favorite people and this has been
a long time in the coming uh we've got
brian forrester from hidden inca tours
brian how are you lovely how about you
good mate yeah good uh i know we've been
we've been threatening to chat for quite
some time
and we're also joined today by jimmy
from the bright insight channel good
friend of mine
and somebody that i've just uh we had
shared we had shared a trip to egypt
yeah jimmy good to see you mate
how's it going great to see you guys
yeah we had a blast in egypt
we had so many things to chat about with
that and this is my first time chatting
with brian forster directly
which is awesome i couldn't be more
excited i've said it a million times
you're the guy i was researching these
ancient topics back in 2015 and i came
across a video
of you at the sarah pm with 100 ton
boxes and
and now here we are five six years later
wow pleasure yeah it's it's great to get
all you guys to get in and like i said
i've i've i've also been talking with
brian's one of the people that got me
originally interested in all of this as
well in fact he was i first met him on
tour in 2013 with graeme hancock i was
uh that was
one of the first exposures i had to to
all of these things and ever since then
i've kind of been pestering brian on and
off
probably for the last seven or eight
years uh we did did some interviews with
him pro
on an older youtube channel and i'd been
down to peru and said hello a couple of
times since then so
yeah i'm great i i'm glad we're getting
the chance to
to chat about all this stuff it's been a
while yeah
so i was uh probably start with
something that that is fresh in
in mind and that is that jimmy and i had
just come back this is the first time
also jimmy that we're getting to to chat
about the egypt trip so we had a what
was a really
intense but also very fun i think trip
uh to egypt in in late november early
december of last year which was kind of
a crazy time
to try and do it but we kind of managed
to pull it off it was it was a
good couple of weeks it was amazing it
was epic
and it's surreal to think that that was
just a little over a month ago that we
were there
it seems like i mean it seems real
recent far more recent than six weeks
ago
um but yeah that being my first time
there and doing it with you and
like you said it was an intense trip we
were busy it was because what we went to
what two dozen sites in two weeks
something like that something like that
yeah it was whatever it was
the packs and uh packed and it was
it was a bit tired some but that's not a
complaint because i've already forgotten
about that part because it's like
everything i saw exceeded my
expectations everything's bigger when
you see it in person
and um but and we'll get into those
details in a second but i just want to
say that traveling with you was
awesome you're a great travel buddy and
you'd already been to these sites what
for
that was your fifth time i think
something like that yeah yeah
and you were just showing pointing so
many things out to me that i had never
even heard of there were so many details
on that giza plateau that i was like i
didn't know that was there
like like these piping systems and those
massive blocks at the top of the cosmic
[ __ ] that just you know
me that's been looking into specific
things like the
sphinx and the pyramid and the blocks
and the technology and there's all these
other nuanced details there that are
worthy of discussion and uh anyway it
was a pleasure to travel with you and
we're gonna do it again
we got to travel together again
someplace we are in fact
yes yeah that's uh in fact we've just
before we started recording this we've
kind of been plotting on uh
on some ideas because that's it's one
thing that i've always also
enjoyed south america and prune
obviously brian lives down lives down in
peru and
uh yeah so we were just talking about
that so if anyone's interested and i
know lots of people on probably all of
our channels are we are
talking and and thinking about putting
together a trip with all three of us
uh down to south american peru probably
even this year so
uh stay tuned uh the next couple weeks
hopefully we'll we'll get those details
worked out we'll announce something and
and
if people want a chance to uh to join us
down in south america and peru
i think that will be coming up in the
near future
we got to make it happen we got to do it
right brian what are you thinking
well it'll be a pleasure to uh to
explore these
places uh with you two and with the
other people
of like mine from around the world
because i've been i've been doing this
for about 13 years so
we have a system down that's very
efficient in terms of moving people
around
and making sure everyone's happy and
blowing their minds with uh you know the
incredible megalithic stuff that's in
in peru and bolivia yeah so yeah
i think it'll be a wonderful experience
yes it should be
yeah in fact brian you you really it's
it's a place that i've only been to once
and it was on that trip with you in 2013
that's that's
i think indicative of the kind of
experience you can get with
a traveling with you and with people
that really know like you i consider you
to be an expert
obviously an expert down there as you
say you live down there you've been
doing this for a long time
but napahuaca is one of my favorite
little nupper and glaziest is the other
name that people use
use for it wonderful little like crazy
megalithic site that's
not on any of the normal tourist
itineraries it's not something that that
many people get to go and see
it's kind of a little journey you've got
to walk up past a river up some train
tracks and then hike up this
uh hike up the side of a terraced uh
hillside in the in the sacred valley to
find this little
uh megalithic cave that's up there made
out of blue stone or granite it's got
these incredible
shaped shapes in the in the in the
granite it's not something that's an
official site or anything but yeah that
was
i assume there's all these little things
like that all over south america that
are just you know not part of your the
regular well-known
um uh parts of it but but that are
mind-blowing nonetheless
uh you know it's stuff like that that it
just to me just like this is
this is there's something else that was
going on down here this wasn't all just
inca work
oh yeah yeah yeah that's a special
little place
um if you look it up on the internet
most commonly
it's listed as nyopa iglesia but that's
a a mix of
an inca word with a spanish word and so
i consulted with my friend wilkin we
decided to rename it
which means the ancient sacred place you
know giving it a
proper inca name rather than a mix like
that but yeah there
are there's still a number of places up
around cusco in the sacred valley that i
haven't been
to yet you know nothing big i bid all
the big ones
but my friend wilco my other friend
and mentor teo they've lived
in cusco all their lives so they know
these subtle little locations
that they want to take me to in the in
the near future
awesome still a lot to learn yes
yeah jimmy that's a i don't know if
you've seen it we have had a video on it
but that's i think that's
definitely a place that we if we if we
all got together and went down there
that we'd go and visit it's um
yeah a real special little corner of
peru
yeah but yeah jimmy one thing i wanted
to ask you is
is and i hadn't had the chance to do
this yet because as i said this is kind
of the first time we've really uh talked
much
uh since the trip but that was your
first trip to egypt right that was
on the tour and and as you said like it
was a
you know when you're there it's tiring
and it's usually a busy schedule but
it's not the part that you take away
from it my i guess my question is what
were your impressions of it and
and you know did you like a lot of
people seem to
seem to feel that when you just visit
egypt but but you often it almost
immediately calls you back like a lot of
people
i've talked to that visit it for the
first time like man i it was just
it was mind-blowing and and such that
you know you almost immediately want to
go back and and go and look at a lot of
this stuff again after you've had a
chance to process it has that has that
been your experience
yeah it there was a special vibe to it
i've been to different places in the
world i'm not like a vast world traveler
though
but there's different places where you
feel better at than others and there was
something about egypt that has such
a good vibe the people were wonderful i
mean i'm talking the most
friendly and welcoming people ever and
it is something about and
people can think what they want but i'm
like there's there was a vibe about it
i'm like i could almost live here if it
wasn't
so crowded because i like a little bit
quieter um
and maybe the pollution is a little bit
much for my for me but like
minus those little things i could see
myself living there for a few months
it was something about it that was
special and i felt like
i felt sad leaving i mean i was there
for 17 nights because i got there two
nights before the
tour started yeah and when i was leaving
i felt sad i mean it's always that
feeling of
that it feels good to go home in your
own bed and you're back into your
routine
but there was something about it i'm
like i already knew i'm like well i'm
definitely coming back
um for a variety of reasons too it was
when you see everything for the first
time and some places you're a little bit
more rushed than others
you know some places you have plenty of
time there and you really have time to
take it in
but still when you're seeing multiple
places a day and you're doing it every
single day
you know it becomes something's become a
little bit blurry i'm like
you know i'm kind of like i mean you
probably saw me i was like
like a kid in a candy store i'm like
looking around i'm like overwhelmed i'm
like where do i take pictures
i think i'm at i play about 23 000
photos between
i took like 8 000 photos on my cell
phone because i wanted some
and then i'm at like 15 something
thousand on my mirrorless
and i'm like i still haven't gone
through all of them um
but you got to answer your question it
it exceeded my expectations
i can't wait to go back and uh i just
had the time of my life there i remember
telling you that when i was leaving to
go to the airport you're on your balcony
at the hotel i'm walking out i'm like
ben thank you i had the time in my life
and the thing is i've been telling
people like more people need to go there
like don't bother go why don't look rome
in in ancient greece i'm sure that's all
wonderful i haven't been either
but i'm like i don't know compared to
egypt that stuff is like child's play
and i say that with respect
but the the stuff that the egyptians did
is next level
everything's huge and it's very
affordable
i mean what is it uh one dollar u.s
15 egyptian pounds like you could go
live there like a king
and um and you can make if you want to
there's different ways of traveling you
go on a tour
if you want to do things on your own
there's different you know cost benefits
going either way but
sure um yeah i i just would encourage
more people to do it and i just can't
say enough about it
and when people ask me like because my
friends and family you know coming home
like so what do you think about it and
like the first
thing that i say i'm like egypt's wild
it's wild yeah well i mean you you guys
are going back right is that all has
that all been finalized and announced is
that all happening
yeah this is the news
you announced it brian i haven't
announced anything on my channel or
anything like that
i was uh i was waiting to get all the
details and this has just been finalized
last few days so
what's happening yeah well we're just
all we're waiting
for is for the poster but um yeah we're
going to be going
um this will be my ninth trip to egypt
so our tour with jimmy is going to be
october 1st
to 14th of uh of this year
and i think it'll be a great time to go
the weather will still be nice it won't
be too hot
people's other concerns they don't have
to worry about
uh most i've heard almost nobody's
wearing
a mask in egypt anymore because it's
just you know
the possibility of catching anything bad
is basically zero
right of course we'll be doing it with
uh patricia
aoian who i've been working with for
about a decade
um and she's with a great company called
select
egypt travel who are very professional
they're great they'll be in niall cruz
there'll be
all sorts of stuff that jimmy has seen
but i don't think you've been to tanis
have you
no we didn't make it out there um
the nature of the tour i mean it was we
basically took a group vote
and we decided to skip it um because it
was going to be like
a six hour drive or whatever and a half
hours away
yeah and um but yeah so we'll be going
there which i can't wait to see because
that place is
incredible and also going down into the
sphinx's paws
because we didn't get to do that we were
up in the above the enclosure
and so going down there by the pause is
going to be is
i want to be down there i need to look
yeah i need to take a peek
inside the sphinx enclosure is is uh
is a good experience i've been down in
there too that's that's worth doing yeah
we
so we we had planned to go to tennis and
but what
it was kind of like a flow-on effect of
what i mean just the
part and parcel of the risks of
traveling in in 2020 late 2020
was that we we had we had originally
planned a nile cruise on ours and um
literally two days before we flew to
luxor we we got the call from
we also used select egypt and they tried
to move the government pulled all the
permits for all the cruise ships
uh so they we had a ship we had a ship
booked we had it all ready to go
but then literally two days as we were
on the tour it was like oh man this is
this has just happened that we they're
not going to let them sail
uh no cruise ships were sailing from
what we could tell
and yeah so we had to pivot and say all
right we do upper egypt by bus which
which you just it ultimately sort of
compounded there's quite a bit of bus
travel and then
and towards the end of the trip it's
like well we've got a day where
tennis and bastet's like a big day get
up early it's three it is it is a long
bus drive from from cairo so we decided
let's
er the group decided let's we'd rather
spend another day at giza
uh which and at the giza you could spend
a week just at the giza plateau just
walking around i mean
easily so yeah we pivoted i'm glad you
guys are getting to tanner so that's
it's absolutely worth the trip
uh and it's worth it's worth the time it
takes to get out there it's it's a
wonderful uh wonderful spot i did a
couple of videos on it it's um
it's some place i do want to get back to
as well uh but yeah tennis is
tennis is awesome no it's i found it
completely
it's probably the most bizarre sight in
all of egypt to me
because before that i'd only seen like
four really bad photographs that had
been taken
of some busted statues but when you get
there it's like a lunar landscape there
no plants grow at tennis because it
looks like it was hit by some kind of
incredible
heat force and just blew the whole place
to pieces there's
12 or 13 massive obelisks that have all
been snapped like styrofoam
everything was found buried underground
so it's very very mysterious
it's in the middle of a police military
compound which is kind of weird but
um i was the first time i went to town
as i was completely
just blown away by it yeah it
me having not been there it looks like
honestly
just from seeing pictures and video that
you've posted i'm like it looks like
evidence of a cataclysm something
yeah terrible happened there it's pretty
apparent
yeah and why else is it all buried under
you know i mean and knocked over and
everything's broken
and and there were massive structures uh
statues and
columns yeah it's it's it's wonderful go
ahead
sorry well one of the you know there are
a lot of
incredible mysteries at tennis too
because you see bits and pieces of
broken
broken this broken that you see obvious
heat scorching
on uh on quartzite pieces and then
there's a foot
that's about seven feet long and
i think it was i i think it was petri or
one of the other archaeologists
who did the initial analysis and he said
that originally you know he found it was
either one or two statues that were
broken
and based on the size of the foot he
estimated the these step this statue of
these two statues were more than a
hundred feet tall
made of one piece of stone and so
when you go to tennis and and you want
to go and walk to the area where all
these
bits and pieces are the military just
tells you to come back
it's an area they will not let you
explore
you know out of bounds but that you know
that is egypt
the key about egypt is to find somebody
who's got a key to open a door to let
you
win key called bakshish in a lot of
cases yeah it's um
yeah yeah yeah yeah you got it there's
definitely a way that that country works
but that so that's i did a video about
that statue in particular yeah it was it
was petrie
and it was what was probably
and possibly the largest stone statue
ever made it was
as you said over like if people have
seen the colossi of memnon this thing
was
another third a taller than those and
uh there's far bigger than the um
the statues the giant big single piece
statues at luxor
uh and and yeah like you said all that's
left of it there's a couple pieces he
found of it there's this one foot
and there's and you kind of have this
big toe and they've got this amazing
picture of him as mohammed ibrahim
your whole whole hand just just fits
inside the toenail like so
in terms of scale more or less a similar
size to the statue of liberty
uh just the structure of the of the of
the statue itself and but made from
one single piece of of grant of granite
and just incredible you
and that's one of the things that tennis
you have you likely had several of them
as well as like avenues of sphinxes and
and uh
columns and obelisks and all giant
megalithic single pieces
it's as you said like this it would have
rivaled i mean this was a place that was
like karnak and you know in scope and
scale probably even
if not even bigger i mean there's just
nothing much left of it anymore
um in fact we i saw something so
incredible
at karnak as well and i think there was
similar statues of a similar scale
i saw something at carnegie's made from
conglomerate which includes flint which
is even harder than granite
uh what's left of a hand and there's a
thumb on that and that thumb was almost
the same size as this big toe so
if you just sort of work on
extrapolating the size and scale of it
you're talking about other statues of
that same magnitude also at
at karnak and this you're talking like
1200 tons 1500 tons
and certainly even more than that with
the one piece of stone and the fact that
it's conglomerate stone is even crazier
because that's
i mean it gets into the the the details
of how to work stone but conglomerate is
in
some ways a much harder material to work
than just granite because you have
this varying degree of hardness of the
material that's in it
uh it can vary wildly like from soft to
hard so
getting those machine surfaces and those
flat edges that which i think are these
you know signatures of advanced
technology and signatures of techniques
that
we can't explain by the tools and
techniques that we have in the in the
archaeological record
or of what we know of the dynastic
egyptians makes me obviously
i think they were inherited but it's
yeah there's that's i think that stuff
was everywhere like
the best the best piece the best the
best example we have of something of
that scale now is the ramesseum
uh there's that that fallen over big
statue
and even that's slightly smaller than
these other statues that we're talking
about and that's just
when you first i had the this trip in
december was the first time i'd managed
to get to the ramesseum
i'd not been there before right yeah and
and
luckily i i was on the balloon we did
the balloon ride over the
west bank so we flew over it i think the
day before or that morning
and then we we got to the ramesem it was
just perfect it was close to sunset the
light was incredible the footage
we have i have from the ramen scene in
the images is just
astonishing and man i tell you what it
hits home when you see the scope and the
scale the sheer size of
of what that statue would have been like
and again one single piece of granite
unbelievable wow yeah
yeah at least yeah it's unreal besides
you're mentioning like being there at
sunset the lighting was fantastic
it was a beautiful sunny day but i
remember thinking like going up
and you're describing before like with
the uh that massive
foot and it's like similar right there i
mean i remember taking a photo of it i'm
like this is lord of the rings
lord of the rings is it based on the
true story it's right here because you
know like in the in the first one
fellowship and they're like
going on the on the canoes down the
river and they're passing by those
massive statues that are like this and
like
and i'm like that's reminds me of i'm
like just standing next to the shoulder
and
you see pictures of it and you see
people standing in front of it and
you're like
that's huge but then when you see
something with your own eyes and you're
right there
it's even bigger i mean i think most
people can comprehend that things look
bigger in person
but we do try to imagine in our minds
what it will look like just based on
those other photos you see with some
dude standing in front of it
but when you're actually there and you
take it all in it is
i knew i was in the presence of
greatness i'm like what
happened here i'm like this place the
precision of that and and by the way
how far did that stone come from that
particular location i don't know if it
was 100 miles or was miles it was
something
yeah it wasn't right there that's right
yeah there's asthma the quarry is still
a significant way even
in upper egypt but again you've got
examples of
of those sort of scale of stone
as far north as tennis like antennas is
the other direction from
cairo 1000 kilometers yeah it's
that's in the delta exactly and there's
no
there's no nile river there to you know
what's right to shuttle
this stuff down it's like brian
uh tree trunks and olive oil come on
yeah yeah that's it well milk
milks the other thing like that milk in
front of the sleds
yeah it's it's funny you know that that
that's a good point because that's the
that's the auth
what we're referring to of course is the
orthodox explanation for a lot of this
stuff which is
well you know it's the car we've got a
scene on the wall where they've they've
loaded a knob that's
a boat and they obviously were floating
these things down the nile and that's
because the as1 quarries about a
kilometer from the null
it's not that close even with the
inundation the nile wouldn't have been
that close
there's and then that's sort of that's
the coverall explanation that gets used
to say well this is how they shifted
shift
shift shipped these huge pieces of stone
now there's a few problems with this
it's something i'm
i'm working on in a video at the moment
but the scene on the wall in sicario
real famous on the causeway i've got
plenty of pictures of it we saw it jimmy
the the obelisks are tiny they're like
the guys standing next to it
it comes up to about chest height like
they have much smaller obelisks there
may be 70 80 ton maximum
which is sure that's plausible you can
i think i think where the difference
starts to show is when you you scale up
to 600 plus tons which
you have a lot of objects in that
category in egypt so i'm sure they were
shipping smaller stuff
on the nile but the other thing is you
have a lot of objects and a lot of
granite
that didn't come from s1 like as1's rose
granite there's a lot of the pink
granite that's where it came from
but you have like the the wadi hammer
met quarry which is in the eastern
desert
there's a number of other queens
right and it's the mountains it's
mountains mountains you have mountains
valleys deserts
no yeah i know rivers and again you're
talking about moving
blocks of stone significant distances
and some in some cases these are 600
even larger blocks of stone and whether
you think they worked on them
on site or they were finished first and
assuming it was a rough block of stone
you know add another three or four
hundred tons because you know that's
they had to shape it yet
it's yeah it's a it's uh we don't know
how
they move them i think it's the truth
but also
you know they show these theoretical
barges for moving like a 450 ton obelisk
what would would they have made the
barge out of right
you know there are no native trees in
egypt
that you can make lumber out of so
automatically people will say
well the cedars of lebanon it's like i
don't think so
you know they have to you know they
always have to give a silly
story that they think gullible people
will swallow and all it takes is
you know medium intelligence to ask a
basic question like
what kind of word oh i don't know this
is the thing
i'll be provocative i'll just say it i
don't even think they're trying to make
gullible
people believe anything i think that
they themselves are the gullible ones
because they have not tested these
theories
they read about it in some textbook that
somebody else made up that didn't do it
these are people that have never been to
the gym a day in their life they don't
know the
the what it takes to lift weight and i'm
not look i'm not dissing them because
they're not
you know muscly or something i'm saying
that when it comes to actually moving
mass
it is different than most people think
and it's not just a matter of like well
hold on a second
if they could do it for this size then
you just add in this many more people
and then that's the because that's what
i've heard them say i've heard these
professors say this so like it's just a
matter of more people like
definitely at a certain level it doesn't
become feasible like how many
how large are these ropes how long are
they in like i don't know i uh
i just think that a lot of these people
like they mean well they just don't
they don't they haven't tested it
themselves and i think that's what this
comes down to
like if i had won the the powerball a
few weeks ago and it was a bunch of
money like i would have
i would have thrown a bunch of money
around to get a bunch of these same
people
to test these things like i'll give you
everything you need and i'm going to
make you
a a small fortune in the meantime we'll
all be friends
and but let's test this stuff let's
really examine these things to see
if you truly believe now after having
tried it
that these are the methods that would
have been utilized um
because there's a lot of debate
obviously we all know this there's a ton
of debate in this community
of ancient history enthusiasts and i
think that we all just want to know the
truth but
clearly there's a mystery here there is
there is and i think there's a couple
there's a couple things going on with a
lot of this one is
is in most cases they're trying to to
fit all of the stonework into the into
the box that
that is this here's the evidence of the
tools and the things that we've found
right so we've found
copper chisels we've found pounding
stones we've found basic
sleds and we've found scenes on the wall
that show them carrying
you know medium or small sized objects
on barges
that's the evidence that's you know and
you go to the museum there's these
little sleds and things there
and they've got the pounding stones so
it's they then look at
everything in egypt from this lens of
well here's here's the tools that we
we know we found and they try and put
and they just they use that to cover
everything that they see and it's
there's a there's a
real lack in um uh
in open-mindedness on this like this
there doesn't seem to be
any room for the idea yeah exactly as a
pounding stand right there's the answer
that's the tool the mystery one is in
egypt that's how they made it apparently
right
but that's there's a thousand times
that's how you do it jimmy yeah we
filmed a couple people trying
their best to make some dust there's a
good video you made actually i like that
um
yeah and it's just good oh go ahead well
i was just gonna say real quick like
those stones are heavier than people
realize like that's one thing i didn't
watch in that little video
when i was holding that that thing is
like 10 pounds it's not light and
it hurts not even chipping it away and
some people will say
i saw some criticism or people saying
well they would have attached them
to wood you know make it like cameras
and i'm like well let me just say this
that's not what they're telling you in
egypt because they made us watch
that video yeah produced by sahih
they specifically show you people need
to understand this like don't believe me
i'm telling you that they make you
before you visit
the oswan quarry go into a classroom and
watch a video where they show them
hitting it with their bare hands
no wood and i don't even think it'd make
much difference if they if they were
not but um this is what they're teaching
so if you disagree
with that method then cool we're on the
same page we we
all agree that there must be a little
bit more to that story because
between those cuts between those uh
those
um uh the uh divots or what i'm trying
to say
the scoop marks thank you oh what 25 26
centimeters precisely for each and
everything one of them
yeah or is it 50 something so if they're
all the same size
that in itself would say that it wasn't
done just by hand people just banged it
away it was something else
yeah um regardless i haven't seen these
people actually demonstrate these
methods with any bit of success
i don't see the ground corners i don't
so yeah don't get me going
no i know there's no way jimmy's wound
up now
this there's there's so much to say
about that all of that and and and the
quarry is a good example there's
you know there i was let me i i can tell
you there's been some studies so so
uh chris dunn's book uh does it
it has a roundup of there's been several
different studies where people have
tried
and and you get wildly different results
both from ancient
from from older archaeologists and and
so on and more modern guys that have
kind of pounded away and figured out the
material removal rates and how long it
would take and how much effort it would
take and
the results vary wildly but you've got a
number of real significant
practical challenges that you can see
with your own eyes uh when you go to ask
one one
is that exactly what you said jimmy is
that the the scoop marks and we found
this out because we had a couple people
on our tour
with iphone the latest iphones that
would light our scan things it turns out
that these scoop marks are a very
uniform width
they're almost exactly all the same
width which is indicative of a
tool that isn't just you know all these
guys sitting in a trench hammering
like you don't have room for starters to
use wood down there because these
trenches are narrow maybe one person
fits in them the other thing
is that these scoop marks not only do
they extend horizontally but they
they're on
underneath the stone so you're not
gravity fine you can drill a hole maybe
this way
but you would also be doing this up in
the air
and and horizontal and that's a whole
different kettle of fish
with this method it's it's it is sort of
patternly nonsense and i think that's
why they effectively try and
indoctrinate everyone that comes through
there sit down watch this 20 minute
video it's like
and it's the music ah the wonders and
it's like an orchestra it's like you
know yeah yeah and
this is how they did it and go and bang
on a stone and just all
it's the i call it the this the national
project
answer like this is a question we asked
zahi back in 2015 on the tours like how
did they do it and his answer to things
like how they built the pyramids how
they did these objects is that
it was a national project everyone
wanted to do it and this is the orthodox
explanation they just said
people would have been felt privileged
to go and work in as a worker in the
granite quarry and uh
during the wet season like you try that
try that for an hour
and get back to me so how you feel after
an hour of pounding into granite and
like not doing anything with it
it's you know it the hot that's it's
this whole house of cards that set up
and i mean i just
the point i was trying to make earlier
is that i think that
there's it's a modern phenomena with our
our orthodox
establishment academics it's it's this
modern phenomena of
of not being open minded to answers that
are outside of
this toolbox that we have from the
ancient egyptians like this idea that
there may be a tool out i think it's we
obviou
obviously there were tools out there
that did this because we have the
results of them
that doesn't mean we've found them and
we and we may never find them but
we have the results of you cannot
explain what happened and this is
this is something that that was was that
petrie knew that that
that that that our older generation of
explorers and archaeologists knew you
know they
they uh they were aware of it and they
were a bit more open-minded to the
mystery and they would speculate as to
how potentially it could have been done
but
they were definitely i think more aware
of and more open to the mystery but it's
it's modern last 50 years almost that
that we've got this we know how it was
done
it was done with these tools that we've
got in the archaeological record and
that's it and it's like
come on there's you can you can poke
holes in that all over the place like
the whole sled
the sled thing drives me crazy like
there was
there's boxes in the serapium that
they're sitting on the ground they were
in transit
trust me if they had just dug under the
corner of one
and they had found the smallest tiniest
fragment of wood
or of some sled that was under that did
that they would have crowed from the
the rafters of their ivory towers that
the mystery sold
we figured it out but they don't do it
because there's no evidence of it
they've you know i'm sure they used wood
to move and sleds and the dynastic
egyptians did all that
but that doesn't explain the real
megalithic stuff
um it's worth mentioning brian i want to
hear your opinion but i just want to
throw this out there because you were
mentioning like this is a human thing
where this goes back hundreds of years
whether it's galileo copernicus i've
mentioned this in some of my earliest
videos like
at one point in time flat earth was the
scientific consensus
at one point it was they would freaking
threaten to torture you to death for
suggesting that we
or that the sun rotates around or the or
excuse me the earth rotates around the
sun
or that we weren't the center of the
universe this was the scientific
consensus this is a human thing we have
to
embrace the fact that we just don't know
everything right and
and it is a human thing to want to be
right and
and that's it sorry my dog was i had to
move the camera he was whimpering i
didn't know if you guys could hear him
so i had to give him some attention
sorry brian i want to hear your opinion
on
on what well on just like whether the
the
like ben said like the ivory tower like
this because you've been doing this for
years
you have been presenting these things
you've gone to these sites more than
so there's a lot of people write
textbooks on these things and yet here
you are you've been to machu picchu 70
what 72 73 times i think you would said
you go to egypt nine
ten times now and all these people and i
won't name names but some of them
haven't even been to egypt once
many of them actually and those that
have many of them it is one time
and um so i'm just curious about your
opinion you've seen it all you've heard
people of all explanations you've heard
the academics you've heard you know the
alternative you know
ideas what's your experience been as far
as you know
what the mindset is on if there's
something that you think is totally
wrong and they're clearly wrong in some
like as we've seen some of these
examples whether it's the stone hammer
thing
um what do you think that's about they
just don't want to believe something new
they just want to believe that their
rights
are they trying to hide something like
what's what's the angle there
well it's a you know it's a paradigm
it's a boy's
it's a boys and girls club more boys
than girls
and they all collectively
reinforce each other's belief in this
collapsing paradigm and that's what's
great about the work that
what the three of us and others are
doing is that we're physically going to
these
locations which is important you can
only
learn so much from photographs in
someone else's video but when you go
there
you see the sense of scale you see the
impossibility of
it doesn't matter how many people you
have working on a project like the great
pyramid
it doesn't matter how many people you
have working it can't be you know it
simply can't be done
you know you you can't move a block
every two minutes
from the quarry and set it into place
and lock everything together it doesn't
work
um so i think the important thing is is
that the paradigm is dying
because more and more people's eyes are
opening to
what is obvious like the the clear
distinction between
what the dynasty egyptians could have
done with their toolbox
and what they couldn't have done what
the inca could have done
what the inca couldn't have done what
the tiwanaku people could have done
what they couldn't have done it you
always get that now you get this
you know if everything was done by these
people and you have simple questions
like
how did they do it and then they give
the silly answer like well they use
bronze chisels and stone hammers and
stuff
anybody with any sense of logic would go
that doesn't work so that's you know
that's where
uh you know we've all gone through some
frustration with this but the you know
the um
it's all working out you know millions
of people are now looking at this kind
of stuff
it's attracting more and more people to
these ancient places because if you can
say
that whoever did this work was
pre-dynastic or pre-inca
it makes the time frame bigger and
bigger and bigger
so you would think the governments would
love this because it would bring in more
tourism
you know if you say this place is 12 000
years old compared to five it's like
uh but you know that's what you know
that's what we're bringing to the table
through our our common sense observation
and videos it's like i can't tell you
who did it but i can tell you who didn't
that's right yeah i can't tell you what
tools they use but i can tell you what
tools they couldn't have used that's
right
that's that's it in a nutshell that that
really is it yeah and that's that's also
a key thing like it
and there's a straw man argument that
always goes along with that for people
that criticize
it it's like well if you if you don't
think that the inca or that the
gymnastics did then you must think it
was
draw from this list it's aliens or this
one's really the other thing right and
it's like
you know i'm not i've never claimed that
and it's it's it's on
the it's a burden of proof uh discussion
really and there's a dishonesty that
goes with that argument it's
i'm not claiming and i don't think any
of us are that we know how it was done
and i am open to all the ideas of where
the evidence goes
even and whatever that evidence shows in
terms of timelines like
i've always said that it either either
the dynastic egyptians for example
didn't do this work
or and and and i think that all evidence
supports that case and that they most
likely inherited it but the other option
is that they did
which means that we've got our our
understanding of them is completely
wrong like we have to rewrite
the history books either way based on
the evidence i think it's
you know it's it's technologically they
were far more advanced if they did do it
and and they had a vastly different
civilization than than what we think of
it
or you know they didn't do it in which
case they
most likely in my mind inherited this
stuff which lends to a longer timeline
and previous civilizations and things
and i think there's
i think there's far more ancillary
evidence now particularly coming from
modern science that supports that
conclusion
things like the younger dryers cataclysm
things you know things like the
extension of the the human
genetic timeline like this is you know
we we keep getting older and older we
keep finding
you know new oldest human remains we
started off at 50 000 years old then we
went to 190 000 years old now we're
something like 350 400 000 years old
based on the latest find
in morocco and that's just homo sapien
sapien you've also got
dennis ovens and floriensis and all
these other types of humans that have
come up and brian this is a question
i've
i want to ask you about it because i
think there's all this evidence for it
in south america too with the elongated
skull people clearly that's a variety of
human
that seems to be pretty consistent it's
not us it's someone else
it's you know there's other things going
on i just think there's a tremendous
amount of
evidence that comes from all these
adjacent fields of science that support
this case of a longer timeline
even if the academics don't like to
touch it and and speculate on it
good examples of the you know the dna
study that came out he's a swedish
scientist forgot his name but he showed
that there's a link between the people
in south america
and the australasians uh early
australasians as a genetic link
that only exists between this part in
australasia and then these people in
south america
does this this indicator doesn't exist
in the peoples of central or north
america
which is really a challenge for the
established story of history because it
means that people
didn't that that genetic link didn't get
there by coming over the land bridge the
whole diaspora of humanity as we know it
means
perhaps there were people crossing the
pacific ocean way back when you know
that
this is the traces of it that we're
seeing now but typically those guys that
like we're just giving you the genetic
study we're giving you the results of
the dna we're not speculating
on what it means for history so it's you
know it's that those sort of walled
gardens of academia
uh in effect a little bit
that's and to go along with that haven't
they found uh mid-eastern dna
inside native american dna in north
america like
that so that goes right along with it
it's like that in itself throws a bunch
of
wrenches inside the the so-called known
human migration process and like what's
mid-eastern
dna doing in in you know north american
uh
you know so think about that
yeah it's it's it all it all points
towards this idea that
we our past is way more complicated than
we think it was right and that's and
that exactly
and and there's also this you know the y
chromosome bottleneck that um
antonio zamora has an excellent video
showing which correlates to the younger
dryer saying it was a huge drop in male
populations
all around the world uh as a result of
the younger dryers because it makes
sense right that was a megaphone
uh extinction event we we are a species
of megafauna
uh and it was a cataclysm the likes of
which the planet hadn't seen in probably
five million years or something and
you know we went through it we survived
and then oh you know what this
funny story this seems to also correlate
with everything all the ancient cultures
say it even correlates with what our
religions say that
the flood myths the the the the fire
miss all these stories of
you know our ancestors going through a
cataclysm barely surviving and having to
restart again you
you know that's that's every single
culture almost it's almost as if this is
a way to record information yeah across
five continents if they have those
those legends and hundreds of cultures
and this is mainstream stuff that they
have documented it's like okay that's
what they say whether it's true or not
but
it's worth mentioning when you say like
that five million years i think
so in the last and this is mainstream
science and last 450
000 years there's been five
inter-glacial periods they're not ice
ages but periods of
glaciers coming and going number one now
right
so like five in the last less than half
a million years so i'm like what's
possible
in one million years and besides that
what would have happened between each
and every single one of those
periods i mean that's like that's
drastic climate change
that would have dr that would have
affected humans i mean this it
appears to me that the earth is a very
volatile place it's rather
as hospital hospitable as it is
for prolonged periods of time then
there's these swings of of weather
whether they happen
quickly or over prolonged periods of
time this earth is constantly
changing and that makes civilization
probably a difficult thing and i think
it all ties into why there's this lost
aspect of our past yeah like
absolutely and and i mean look whether
people
they can argue we can argue all day i
mean i'm sure people will
about you know climate change i mean
there's a very political discussion but
the the fact is
is that the i i really do say that the
the reason our civilization
and i really believe this is it got to
the point that it has
is because of the really lovely weather
that we've had for the last eight
thousand years or so like
that we honestly if you go back and all
you have to do is go and look at the
greenland
uh or and the antarctic ice core records
that show you
like they basically it's incredible and
this again only happened last 20 years
this is new information
as far as the long story of history goes
they drill down through the ice and
every year
the snow gets laid down and it gets
compressed into ice and from that they
can
they've been getting better and better
at looking at things like global
temperature and
the amount of co2 and other isotopes in
there that show us a detailed sort of
climate history of the last
four or five hundred thousand years and
it was a very volatile place in
particular like the younger dry ice this
is how all information that's correlated
stuff like that but
since then we've had a period of calm in
over the last eight thousand years in
terms of of the climatic conditions on
this planet nice warm
you know warming slowly perfect for life
that's we haven't had a period like that
for the last something like 250
000 years and that's i think one of the
major things that's enabled our
civilization to flourish and
even through that civilization we've had
little various ups and downs
uh that and and people don't know
realize it but but things like the um
the plagues and the and the dark ages of
of
you know all these things they correlate
to cooling events like to cool
periods of cool the renaissance
correlates to
the you know a warming we basically once
we we came out of
of the dark ages i mean that was a the
earth was cooling's one of the reasons
that
there was famine that encouraged disease
you had the the all of the
the plague bubonic plagues and things
happened and then as
as as we came out of that and started to
warm slightly crops became more
plentiful we flourished the renaissance
started like this
we're very much tied in our civilization
our prosperity is tied into the
the weather on the planet i mean and
that's where we just it's we have it
really good like
it's there's no real sign of it of it
stopping either for that matter but
uh certainly not in comparison to what
happened you know the actual climate
dike i like to call actual climate
change
which was what happened after 12 and a
half thousand years ago um
yeah yeah anyway i have a
to to mix it up a little bit i have a
question for each of you so whoever
wants to go first one
ben this was your fourth fifth trip to
egypt so i'm curious what about
is there something that you learned or
something that surprised you on this
trip
and then for brian for when we go in
october what is it that you're most
excited to see and
whoever wants to go first i'm i'm very
curious
go ahead ben uh yeah so for me it was
a couple things actually so i had some
firsts uh one was the bent pyramid
astonishing place i mean i that was i
had been looking forward to getting in
inside there for forever and as
uh you know you showed in your video
there's
it was opened for the first time in 2019
so that was like a revelation it's a
very confusing place there's a lot going
on in the bent pyramid and
since coming back and studying a little
more like keith hamilton's guides the
architecture in that in that
place is phenomenal like there's so much
going on inside the bent pyramid that
warrants further study uh that it's
i i'm just i think that's represents a
real mystery i don't for a second
believe that it was a mistake in terms
of the angle change in it and in fact
people don't know this either it's
actually it's it's in one of the
an earlier interview i did with yusuf
that's somewhere on my channel
but we'd talk about it because there was
a study done to try and confirm this
theory they actually drilled in because
the idea was that oh well there was an
accident like they had it they were
building the pyramid
and it collapsed and that's what caused
them to change the angle
and if there was a collapse on the
internal structure there'd be some
evidence for it so they went and did
some drilling
into it around that that that angle
change and they found no evidence
whatsoever
of a collapse or of any issues so it's
like they they went out and tried to
just to prove their theory of a collapse
and they ended up disproving it
not something that gets widely widely
publicized in the in the in the orthodox
world but
yeah between there was there was uh
there was that and then
um and then the other thing that uh i
was
i was um what was the other thing that i
came out of egypt with that i was just
blown away by uh it was primarily the
the bent pyramid but you know i
continued to find things around giza the
osiris shaft i mean that to me was
another thing that uh blew my mind
just and this is creepy and just in this
like i wasn't ever sure exactly where it
was on the plateau and then you see it's
right on the causeway between
the kufra pyramid and the sphinx it's i
just think it's like literally
it's it's i mean you know that there is
so much more under the ground there like
this
is evident i think it's direct evidence
that there's a connected system of
tunneling
and chambers that runs beneath the
sphinx beneath the pyramids beneath the
plateau
you know i've and i think it's all i
just i think it blows my mind we don't
do further work exploring that or we
don't
we don't just hammer that place with
ground penetrating all of the modern
techniques to try and map it out because
i can tell you from being down in the
catacombs in saqqara and some other
places
and it's a video i'm working on right
now in fact is about sakara
there's a lot more going on under the
ground at these particularly these old
kingdom sites than
than we we ever thought uh possible and
i'll stop there and let brian answer his
yeah and and real quick just to throw in
there because you're talking about the
bent pyramid
i have a video on it and to anyone
that's interested in learning more about
it go check out annie xt's video
apparently he has a
two hour video on that and i can't wait
to see it and yeah just came out so
people should check that out because he
was uh in there about a year before i
was even in there when it first opened
up so i'm i bet there's a ton of info in
that video that would be
outstanding so props to annie xd yeah he
does good work and if i've started
watching that video i haven't finished
it but yeah it looks it looks he's done
a lot of research on it
looks great yes so brian where do you
wanna
we're going to october what's on your
what's number one on that list or num
and number two maybe perhaps as well
well the great thing about egypt is that
um as time goes on
rather than other countries that are
closing
the mysterious aspects of these places
off with ropes and stuff egypt's
actually opening stuff up
yeah so the osiris shaft has only been
open for like
four years maybe to the general public
and um
and you know going underneath the step
pyramid at sakhara that's been only been
open
for like a year or something so
i yeah i focus obviously my focus is on
pre-dynastic evidence so i find the
dynastic works very
very beautiful i find ancient egyptian
spirituality very
very nice but they don't intrigue me
the way that the enigmatic massive scale
stuff does
such as the rpm of course which has
i don't know if you guys had the side
door metal door open
because you know it's much bigger it's
bigger than what most people
realize it is yeah some people think
that there's a whole series of
tunnels that keep going um the osiris
shaft
is absolutely mind-boggling tanniness is
surreal
uh going into the pyramids themselves
are great i can't wait to see the
the box that you guys recently filmed
that had the really incredibly precise
corners
oh yeah that's the stuff that's still
you know that that's why i keep going
back to egypt
is because actually i can't get enough
visits to these enigmatic places that
conventional
academics basically don't they don't
even look at they don't try to explain
them they don't try to explain
how the boxes of the serapium got in
there without there being any kind of
of soot on the ceiling or you know
whatever that kind of stuff and how they
were put down into the niches
you can see the obvious sign where the
one is still in the hallway so you have
the box
then you have to live they're both
unfinished so somehow the box was
supposed to go into the niche then the
lid comes along
gets put on top gets marked you know
in order to finish gets taken off finely
tuned and then
the lid goes on and hermetically seals
the vessel
i mean come on yeah yeah that's
hurt i would you just reminded me i
would add lahoon pyramid and
particularly that box
to my revelations uh from that last trip
because i i'd heard about
i just heard about la they've opened up
this lahoon pyramid it's really cool in
my heart it's like because it's
one of those middle you know they say
mud brick pyramid you know it's not it's
like
it's i would i would consider to be an
egyptian attempt at copying some of the
the older stuff
but again it's again it's another case
of something that's
uh i think dynastic and low-tech built
on top of of a subterranean
um uh structure and objects that are
obviously very high tech and i think
this happened
a lot with a lot of nuance at these
places where the gymnastic egyptians
used these sites and then they they
respected they built on top of them
i think that's what's going on because
that box is insane it's it's it's not
that
it's not the biggest one you've ever
seen but it's ins it's actually inside
a granite room like the whole room is so
precisely made it's an arched ceiling
the only other arch ceiling i've seen
like that's the one inside the the third
pyramid
and i think that one's made from
limestone but this one's a granite
room with granite arched pieces
beautifully made and then yeah this box
that's
you know thousandths of an inch in terms
of perfect and when it's petri
when i went and dug up the information
on after petrie measured it and he just
called it
you know perhaps the finest piece of
work ever executed in such a tough
uh and unforgiving medium like that's he
thought it was the the finest piece of
like precision sculpture he'd that had
ever been done and
as far as i know it probably it is
certainly ancient
um it's it's sort of we could we can
maybe attain those levels that we can
i'm sure retaining those levels of
precision now with our
cnc machine guided tools but yeah trying
to
trying to suggest to some guy going you
know like lining up his thumb at the
you know that looks pretty flat and
straight to me yeah
exactly yeah that thing was yeah
that thing's evidence that they had more
than what they'd claimed that i don't i
didn't even know what existed
so you told me about it we're on the way
there you're like hey you're telling me
exactly what you said it might be the
one
the most precise you know uh box ever
made or you know or stonework
and then when you're there seeing it and
people had their laser pointers and
they're like doing
one end to the other end this thing was
perfection
yeah and then it had like that slant at
the bottom like to go along with every
room i'm like what
well no so yeah the room is level like i
had to figure this out that the room is
level the box appears to be slant like
it's
it's a tricky thing to really see in
there because the perspective is a
little wonky just looking at it
but the room's level the box is tilted
so the top of it looks like it's built
is tilted but the actual insides are
straight like it's
the whole thing sort of slanted over a
bit and it must have been functional
there must have been a reason that they
did this i
it's it take it took me a while to
figure out exactly what was going on but
but you can get it you can pick it up
from petrie's measurements there's
yeah but there was there was some reason
that they made it that way it was it's
so
precise and and in terms of its relative
dimensions at each corner and each shape
you know they this they did that
deliberately this wasn't a mistake and i
just have no idea without a doubt
there has to be a reason for it and then
brian you mentioned the other thing
about this european was the side door
um yeah not on this trip so there's a
funny story attached to it too
so for people that don't know i i do
have videos on my channel of going in
there
in the sarah pm series uh next to like
this big rose granite box
there's a big green set of doors that
leads to a
it's not finished they're not it's not
finished being renovated or whatever
they're doing
but i've in previous trips there have
been in there and it has
inside all these other alcoves and
there's there's you see one of the big
granite stele's that was inside all of
the alcoves it's busted up in one area
but it also has
my favorite box in the whole place which
is this
massive one of the biggest ones in there
big black granite box that's tucked away
in a corner
in this unfinished area and and i show
that box on my channel got some videos
of it and um
yeah so we we wanted to get in there and
we would have
had not the almost entire sakara staff
been
sort of dismissed and uh
sort of put on the you know put in the
sin bin for one of a better term
because of some there were some so
apparently at the same time we were in
egypt there was some some
some some woman had had rolled up and
she was running around taking these
uh what can i say instagram style risk
sort of photos at the sites like
dressing up like some sort of
forgive the term but some sort of [ __ ]
pharaoh queen
like it's just a big provocative you
know busty girl that was taking these
pictures and then
of course egypt's fairly conservative
right it's it's
this is not a good thing to be doing in
a muslim country like that and
anyway so and also fairly disrespectful
to the culture honestly
and you know she so she was she did this
and she did it at one
site and then there's a picture and then
it she also did it at zakar and then the
government figured it out
and they basically [ __ ] can the entire
staff because of it
and of course that was included our
connection that had the keys to the door
the guys on site didn't even have the
keys to the padlock to open that door
but otherwise we would have got in there
um but i didn't
i did hit i'm sorry i wanted to tell you
sorry after yeah i want one last thing
about this
the seraphim is that i did hear a very
interesting rumor
from some people that have that work on
that site
and on around sakara in general that
that they may have discovered
a whole other extension to that place
and there might be as many as 20 more
boxes
um uh yeah in another set of galleries
so we'll we'll see guys working there
said that's worth mentioning a person
that
works there every day that's what he
said right like that's what my
understanding was
that's worth mentioning like it's you
know something yeah
it's not just a rumor well i i would
class it as an unverified rumor at this
point but it was
you know it's certainly something that
i'm going to try and look into a little
more and we'll see you know i i think
there's a
i agree with what brian said about egypt
opening up more and i think that's
because there's been a change of the
regime in the
in the antiquities department and he's
very
he seems very the new guy seems pretty
keen about doing this and you can tell
like
they they're making discoveries and and
so it's every month or two you'll see
something in the news oh they found this
they found
and i think it's all trying to build up
to the opening of the new grand museum
so it's possible that they've made this
discovery and they're sitting on it and
that they'll be
they're going to wait to get that so it
has maximum impact on the world stage
because
you know when they finally do open up
that grand museum they want dignitaries
and kings and queens and all this sort
of nonsense
they want so they're going to try and
build up i'm sure it's a coordinated
strategy
you know i'd like to think that that
sort of stuff will see the light of day
obviously i'd like to know the answer
now
if they found more boxes like that
particularly if they're sealed and then
but who knows i i think there's if it
has happened i think there's a chance
we'd see that closer to
the opening of the the great pyramid if
they've discovered something well if
they would
if they simply let us know the three of
us could plug it on our channels
well actually if you notice when you
when you walk down the steps to get into
this european
yeah at the top on the left hand side i
was able to get into that it's always
been taboo i was able to get into that
area
somebody has sealed off like a big
series of chambers or rooms there in
relatively recent times
so i think i think that's the location
of the extension of the serpent
it keeps it keeps going off in that
direction yeah that's interesting
also um you know even archaeologists
will say
that only about 15 of ancient egypt
has been unravelled or
earth or whatever you want to see but
most people will then say
well the other 85 is under the sand but
they don't understand
the other 85 is underground it was
built on purpose underground and that's
why you also hear the stories like from
abdel haqui mauian of
a tunnel connecting sakara with the giza
plateau because he went through it when
he was a kid and all this kind of stuff
so
yeah there's a lot more that we could
explore as time goes on
for sure yeah yeah that's a crazy
something i
yeah because did he say that he had
walked it was like eight miles
like as the bird flies right through the
line of sight like eight miles
and and people need to realize yusuf
zayan's father
did that as a kid like he's not making
that up like it's i mean people can
think what they want
but i believe it why would he lie about
something like that um i totally believe
it and we already know that there's all
this infrastructure under the plateau as
it is
um we'll be discussing this in our
videos with all those shafts that you
see along the plateau and you see that
there's tunnels that go horizontal
through them i've got some great
pictures
people can see and think for themselves
and some of them are gated off
and it's like there's things there i
don't know what's there um
i hope my dog is wearing i have to feed
him in a second don't worry we're not
getting off
i don't know if you guys can hear it can
you hear me he's like he thinks there's
something wrong with me because i'm
talking alone
he's not if i could be on the phone
walking around he doesn't do anything
but when i do a facetime
he thinks there's something wrong with
me oh yeah german shepherds are the best
they look after you
wants to participate yeah i know i've
got my door shut because my dog's out
there too so
yeah something i want to mention real
quick going back to with um
that lady was taking provocative photos
a lot of people were asking like hey did
you get a chance to hike the pyramid you
go to the top of the great pyramid
and a lot of people don't understand
just how tightly the security is
uh i mean there was guards everywhere
and when we were there in the great
pyramid we went at night
and there was guards everywhere and
apparently
the story and i think ben you're the one
that had told me this or someone told me
that some couple went up there they
snuck up to the top
and they they filmed the porno up there
like they banged and filmed it and put
on the internet
and that's apparently is the reason why
the egyptian government like doubled up
their security
and they hired like a third party uh
security company to lock that place down
like you can't get on the steps like i
climbed up one set of steps just to get
a picture
and they're blowing their whistles at me
yelling at me like they're not messing
around like no one's allowed on that
thing and
apparently that that was the reason why
or one of the reasons
yeah you'll you'll find that out brian
too that dates one thing i've noticed
that they did do is they've added a rope
barrier
around the great pyramid they kind of
like i mean you can if you if you're
rolling with yusuf or whatever i mean
whatever hop over and and be around
they'll tweet the whistle at you a bit
and and all the locals are kind of
ignoring it and running you know kids or
kids are on the first couple courses of
the pyramid a lot but they have added a
barrier and i'm sure
when when when tourism gets back in full
swing now those
those guards love love telling people
what not to do so
um it's kind of a little i'm like no
that's you know
that's one of those things you can't you
can't quite get right up onto that the
first course of it and that wasn't there
a year or so ago um so they've
yeah about whatever that's that's the
way it goes same
same thing as those blasted blue ropes
at
timonaku and pumapunku right they keep
more of those things
so yeah they they said it was temporary
and
it's not temporary no no
if you pay the lady who who runs the
little
kiosk thing who takes the tickets if you
go there first thing in the morning and
give her a tip she'll let you go in
there
until other tourists show up so oh nice
it's always good to know it's always
local influence
yes and timing is is always the
important thing
so that's why we go to puku first then
we go to tiwanaku because almost nobody
goes to puma
punku they all go to tiwanaku and then
go home yeah
so all subtle stuff like that yeah
that's that's a good point in fact
i'm still that's one place man i still i
am still working on a video i still have
poznanski's volumes here
i have i have managed to find myself his
his two volumes and
and uh yeah that's a video that's been
ongoing for almost a year in terms of
writing and researching for it that i
will
i will be doing a big thing on at some
point but
there's a lot more to to discover i
think and and talk about when it comes
to
pumapunku and tiwanaku like jimmy you
can't wait to you because you haven't
seen those either right
i can't wait to now if you yeah we all
go together you see those places because
that's
really like nothing else on the planet i
mean it's hard to
overstate the how how enigmatic
pumapunku and it's all one side but they
call it two separate things but
and it was found varied correct like i
think brian i was watching your videos
it's all under dirt like 16 i don't
remember the how much but like
it was all found wrecked and they pieced
it back together what they thought
should look like and it's not
at all what they what was actually who
knows
it's in the mud yeah they've done a nice
job restoring parts of it
but you have to also understand a lot of
what you're looking at is a is a modern
restoration
um but there's tons of just a lot of the
interest comes from the blocks that
haven't been restored like the stuff
that's just sticking out
of a wall somewhere where they've been
like you know clearing and then
you find these mass perfectly shaped you
know pieces of andersite that are
most intricately carved and they're just
ah we haven't been we haven't bothered
to excavate this all the way
you know this is just like all the other
stuff that we see out here and it's it's
just one piece of it's kind of
mind-blowing in in in complexity you
want to talk about
just like teasing and and blowing you
know like
knocking away the idea of using hand
tools and and sort of primitive tools to
make stuff it's like they were
just toying with it like there's no
rhyme or reason for the amount of
interior 90 degree tri-linear corners
that are at that place and it's just
like oh we just did this because we
could it was
i don't you know it's it's such a such a
strange place and there's just
there's so much detail in a lot of the
stonework there that's just
don't know how they did it we got to see
it we got to go there this year i got i
got to see it
yeah yeah yeah
gotta get the shot mate yeah we just
heard that a lot
that's good i look forward to it yeah so
with pumapunku i think uh one thing that
i'm working on that's very interesting
about that site
uh is is specifically how it's dated as
well this is another anomaly
in history it's that there is yeah the
orthodox dating what's what what do they
say this was built brian was like fairly
recently like 1100
a.d that's what they say between
100 a.d and 1100 okay so in that period
but
yeah it's it's it's pretty obvious that
there's a nuance of of
layers of cultures that may have used
that site but i'm digging into what you
know poznan's dating of it based on
uh the same technique that kind of gets
used in giza and elsewhere which is
astronomical dating based on alignments
to
particular constellations and you know
an understanding of the the great
the great year that the 26 000 27
thousand year
procession of the equinoxes and the way
that site was originally laid out as he
as pozninski found it
led him to speculate that it may be as
old as 12 to 15
000 years old and and that it did it
aligned specifically to
constellations based on that great year
and one and people he gets a lot of
criticism for that idea
he's not around to defend himself from
it anymore and but but
very few people have i think really read
what he wrote and one of the things that
he said
was that he was very open-minded to
other
interpretations and he acknowledged that
he this was only at the
early stages of the science that would
be required to accurately date this site
and that he hoped
that going forward future generations
would continue to refine and enhance
this
this science of trying to use alignments
and and figure out
how things were were set up because one
of and
one of the problems with that though
these days is is that in the modern
reconstruction of that site in tijuana
specifically is that they've moved
things around so you don't actually have
the same alignment targets they've
reconstructed it
and shifted stuff from the original uh
plan so that's why i think it's
important to go back and look at the
original records and and
of course arthur poznan spent you know
50 years excavating that site he's
pretty much
you know his books and his material
contain all of the original as
found kind of ground plans for that site
um
yeah interesting place well also what
a lot of people don't know because i've
been there
i've been to uh pumapuku and tiwanaku
between
50 and 60 times and i i have the
i have the privilege of going with uh
antonio portugal
who will join us if you guys come on the
august tour
he spent like 40 years with
archaeologists studying the site
they were able to do ground penetrating
radar
yeah and they found massive hollow
chambers underneath pumapunku
that have never been allowed to be
excavated so that's you know that's
ground penetrating radar of the site and
recently
they did liondar from a quadcopter i
think
and they found out that what's
underground is much much bigger than
what's above ground
so now the the government has the
government has to
not necessarily excavate but they have
to come up and tell the truth that
are much bigger than what they suggest
right wow well there you go
yeah i mean that's scientific evidence
that shows that it is
there's things under there it hasn't
been excavated so proof
that there's more to it you know what it
even matches with the some of the
indigenous
sort of rumors and and things that go
around that site
i mean rosemary i think i put you in
touch with her she's got a place she's
she's sort of descendant from the
the peoples of that area and she would
tell you about tales of where they said
there were
stairs leading down and there were uh
evidences of of these underground
chambers
in the indy park or underneath the
pyramid there and that that's
since all been covered up like there's
actually stories from
people of that there were these
staircases and things that led down into
the underground there which
yeah i i would i would believe that as
well yeah i think there's
a tremendous amount more work that could
happen in that area i mean it's funny
too it's
it's as i think you've pointed out i've
seen on your channel like they've
it's a big site that's all a big
boundary around it but by no means does
that encapsulate the entire scope
of scale of what's there you've got
farmers fields on either end of this
thing that have these blocks in them
from that are clearly the same origin
these undecide shaped blocks you know
that place was probably far larger back
in the day
well and and also not to mention the you
know the little village of
of tiwanaku where the foundations of the
houses
are made from stones from puma
oh wow yeah and the church the church
which is there which is about
ten times the size of what it should be
for a town of that size
uh local people say that's the epicenter
of pumapuku
is what's underneath the church yeah
oh you know an extension of it going
that way shocker
wow the the old the human nature aspect
of of of
reclaiming renovating and reusing raises
its head once again
it's um yeah you got the parthenon in
rome you've got the cory cancer in cusco
you've got the church
at uh at timonaku
yeah i mean it's funny in cairo and then
you got cairo
yeah oh god yeah i mean most and stuff
built from the stones
you know from the pyramids half the town
the same thing in cusco even like
spanish villas like when the colony like
that they
quarried the heck out of such a woman to
build them the churches in cusco are
fascinating
you can just see the the different like
where they've taken megalithic blocks
and tried to plaster
them together and then they've had to
use local stone it's something these
buildings just have so many different
styles of architecture which is
one of the reasons i find it so
fascinating
well another point with that is that um
when you and i and ildi and the others
were
were filming at um san cristobal
church yep which is up on the hill below
sac state le mans
um i would walk past that every day
because that's how you get to cusco from
where
where we were living and there was a
gate
that was always locked and it said
bathroom
so you know that's very curious one day
i was walking by and there was a guy
in there cleaning the bathrooms so
he let me go inside and uh he said
there's a tunnel there's a shaft that
goes straight down
connecting with a tunnel system so
that's you know that's local
information and he said i clean i clean
all of the toilets in all the ancient
churches in cusco and each one has a
shaft that goes down and connects with a
tunnel
so there you go yeah you know
if there's one thing and i know because
there's so much debate inside the
community of lost ancient history
enthusiasts
whether it's the technology aspect and
the ages and the dating and all that but
if there's one thing
that i wish that would unite whether
it's the mainstream
scholars and verse the alternative
people that have
could unite everyone is that there
clearly is
there are things that none of us are
aware of
that are worthy of exploration and if
there's one thing everyone could
agree about is that none of us have all
the information and we are
i believe entitled to it this is
humanity
this stuff existed long before anyone
was alive
and i don't know it'd be nice to see if
at least something that could bring
everyone together and be like hey
where do these tunnels go if it goes
nowhere okay but i want to see a picture
and video of it
going nowhere show me yeah kind of thing
yep
yeah i agree absolutely agree and
speaking of tunnels that go nowhere
there was uh
we just had a quick break we were
discussing one there's there's uh and
this is
i think an opportunity that you guys are
gonna have on your upcoming egypt trip
which is
uh going and looking at the tunnel that
supposedly goes nowhere at the
at the back end of the sphinx which is
only accessible
with the special permission to go down
and stand you know in the sphinx
enclosure this is
an aspect of visiting egypt that is
worth uh is worth understanding is that
there's
a lot you can see and do on your own as
a tourist but but going with a group and
this was the focus of our trip in
december was
you know we had five or six special
permissions on them and and that's one
of the benefits of going in a group is
that there are certain things that you
can only do with a special permission
that
you know it costs several thousands each
of them cost several thousand dollars
which is why you have a group to help
everyone have the experience and share
the cost
uh things like you know getting into all
the chambers of the great pyramid
renting that thing effectively for two
hours getting into the sphinx enclosure
there's the uh you know getting into the
uh the assyrion which
which we did on our recent trip but yeah
you guys have got the chance to get down
in between the paws that's going to be
that's going to be fun
yeah well yeah oh sorry go ahead brian
go ahead okay well another you know
there's just so many subtle things
that's why we're gonna have to keep
doing these podcasts because there's so
much stuff we can discuss
all night but but another simple thing
about the sphinx is that
they're in between the paws of the
sphinx there are a series of planks
like in a grid system that are there and
muhammad ibrahim was our guide that day
and i said why did they put this here
because
you have a stone staircase coming down
then you have sand and you know
stuff and he said they built that series
of wooden planks to hide the access to
the underground
system under the sphinx and
what would happen is in the late 90s at
one o'clock in the morning heavy
equipment would go up there
they'd lift up the planks and they would
start doing excavation and this is from
the aoian family then they'd say
at about five o'clock in the morning all
the lights of the machines would be
turned off they'd go back down and leave
the complex so again it's the local
information
which is the most profound because
that's you know that's local people
seeing stuff
in their neighborhood yeah and that's
that's where you get these insights that
there's much much more
especially to the underground system in
egypt than what
almost anybody wants to fess up to
yeah yeah i've heard a similar story
like that that place has been
there was at some point there was a
concert that they tried to do you know
occasionally they do these things this
might have been a couple decades ago
and they and they basically erected a
stage and a
and a tent or or like a covering over
the front of the of that area between
the pores of the sphinx
and for a couple weeks is a one night
concert but for a couple of weeks
apparently there were dump trucks going
back and forth and all this stuff
happening
beneath the cover of this stage and and
after i think after that period was when
they
they they they ended up putting that
wooden floor down because people don't
realize there is a paving stone like
the sphinx is shaped from bedrock but
that area between its paws
and and the front of it there's actually
you know people call it these roman
paving stones there's definitely a
paving stone system on the ground there
and yeah for sure there could be
that that means that that could be on
top of something there could be you know
openings there and
you know there's a as you say the a1
family and those guys they literally
live across the road from it sit there
staring you i mean mrs falcon you sit
there staring at the sphinx and the
pyramids you can watch it 24 7.
um so i'm sure there that the locals see
that sort of activity and that doesn't
surprise me in the least
um you know when it gets to like all the
speculation and
things that have happened uh you know in
the other entrances into the sphinx body
we mean there's
obviously one at the rear end uh that
has a little wooden grate
across it you know that's uh supposedly
goes nowhere
uh according to mark lena but but brian
you were saying like
he did spend a couple weeks determining
that it went nowhere
yeah and there is if you stick your head
in there there is a metal ladder that
goes down
yeah so where does the ladder go to you
know
and there's a tunnel yeah and does that
connect up with the osiris
shaft tunnel system you know that's
what's great about
keeping going back is the you know first
time you go
you want to look at all the big stuff
then second third fourth
you start to pick up all the subtleties
of stuff
and objects you hadn't seen before and
uh so
it's getting into the subtleties and
connecting the dots
as you go and that's why i'm very
excited to be going in october with
jimmy because
we were going to go in march but like
next month that
the world is too chaotic at the moment
to do stuff like that but i think
everything will settle down
and it'll be fine to uh to do these
explorations as well if you guys want to
come
in august to peru and bolivia too then
you know the tour is already set up it's
on the website
the whole itineraries there everything
so that would be a
it would be very exciting to be with the
two of you in the field
that's it you know i'm used to working
with with old guys older older guys
having younger guys with uh fresh you
know fresh eyeballs
we'll bring them apart for me yes that's
good
yeah yeah stay tuned couple hopefully in
the next week or so we can we can figure
out those details and
announce it uh on our channels and yeah
and all that sort of stuff because i
know i know for cert for me
i have a lot of people asking like when
are you going to get down to south
america again and
when's that going to happen so hopefully
we'll have something to say about that
in a week or so
and a lot of people because i mean as we
know times are crazy so
ben you know we traveled in november
december of 2020 which
i mean people were asking me like why
are you what are you doing like what
like i'm crazy i'm like get busy living
or get busy dying
i'm like i can't stay cooped up for the
rest of my life and
i won't be held down by fear and
everyone has a right to choose what they
want to do with their
with their lives and what was
interesting about our group that we went
with
which i also believe will be the same
exact case for later this year
is that there's a certain type of person
that's willing to travel under these
worldly circumstances and it was good
vibes we had a fantastic tour
there's people i'll be in touch with for
the rest of my life and and
and that's what i'm saying like so our
tour was great and brian like
you know when we go it's gonna be the
same thing people that are willing to
take a risk
because there is risk you know what i
mean it's like okay you know like what
there's so many unknowns in the future
as far as travel restrictions or
whatever
but i am optimistic and um hey where
there's a will there's a way and like i
said get busy liver and get busy dying
like this
this is a profound opportunity to see
these sites while they're virtually
empty
right which is what we had the privilege
of doing when we went and i'm
convinced it's gonna be the same thing
over the next several months
that many many places are not going to
be
people are not going to be traveling
like they once were at least not anytime
soon so now it's still a
profound opportunity to go and see these
sites like never before
yeah and that's we're offering a bit of
bakshish which is a bribe
has the opportunity of doors opening
that nobody else has access to because
that's right
uh you know egypt's going through a very
tough time and so
there's an incentive for there's always
a person who
you know that's what abdel kim al-jan
would say it's a
let's find whoever has the keys and
that's
that nobody had access to it's a little
bit of back
sheesh and you know you get five minutes
to go down the staircase and come back
out or whatever but um
you know that's how it works that is how
it works yeah grease the skids cross the
palms
things can happen like that's that's the
joy of yeah and again these two is
using guys why is so much value guys
like yusuf and and
and and mohammed and all the people that
typically that you would use in it on a
tour like that and travel with
know how that systems work system works
and you can yeah for a little bit of
backseats you can you can make things
happen which is good and it's
you know always you want to be
respectful i mean i understand they they
close off access they're trying to
preserve
sites when you do it do it respectfully
and i'm never going to hurt anything i'm
always just going there i'm interested
in looking i'm not going to
i'm not interested in defacing or doing
anything silly so
you know it's it's i think it's all in
in the in
in the in the in the spirit of the right
cause and as you said jimmy i think we
all
we all have a right to understand some
of this our shared
history our shared past because i think
a lot of this stuff this is some of the
few places
where we really have this evidence for
it there you know there's you can't
you know unfortunately there's only a
few places around the world where we
have these remnants and we
they've that's why they're so profound
and they're so special and i think they
feel so
emotional when you visit right there's a
weird there's a weird left brain right
brain connection i think you know
the first time i went to egypt i was
expecting to have this analytical
approach to it
and i was going to go and just try and
understand it from this technological
perspective but you can't help but feel
it
when you when you go there right there's
there's an emotional feeling there's an
attachment like you
it and that's a it's a profound it has
this profound nature that i wasn't
expecting but
it hits you the first time you really
see the pyramid you go and stand in
front of them and look at them it's just
it's unavoidable and that's and i know
guys like christine have had the same
experience we're just like wow there's
this connection to it there's a profound
nature to it and that's
we all should we all have the right to
experience some of that so
yeah yeah well said i felt it too
it was like and people can i don't care
what they think i almost wonder if it's
like a dna memory type thing which dna
memory does exist they've proven this in
dogs and other animals
um i almost wonder i mean it's something
it's like i knew it it felt
good and in certain places there did not
feel good actually i'll say that
and i wasn't expecting it but the cairo
museum
the valley of the kings and the osiris
shaft all gave me
terrible vibes and i know that sounds
silly some people just like oh whatever
i'm like oh okay well valley the kings
that's the tomb and
sound shaft is a tomb and like so of
course it's weird and like it's just in
your head but like
i wasn't thinking that when i went in
there but those two places aside the
cairo museum
many people said that they had a weird
feeling in there and yusuf said it's
like it's because it's
the congregation of all these different
types of things that have
each individually have all these
different energies to them
and again some people can just move that
off but for me i'm like i felt something
in there i felt drained and exhausted in
a different way and it was
i don't know maybe it's because he had
dead people mummies right there on
display
and maybe there's something off about
that but i don't know i felt it before i
saw those mummies but
there's something weird about these
places but it's worth experiencing and
i'm going back to all three of those
places
i'm going back in that osiris shaft yeah
yeah and you're right i mean and yusuf
does talk about like it's that you don't
have
those pyramids don't feel like tombs
when you're there it's it's a different
feeling i mean and the museum is a bit
like i'd liken it to
about i'd feel about the same i i would
as if i'd spend about 30 minutes in a
in a in a modern shopping mall like that
just drains the energy right out of me
i definitely felt that after a few hours
in the egyptian museum there's a
also definitely an energy to it well i'm
just like i'm that guy that's like
dragging along i don't want to go
shopping
time to go walking wrong along behind
the wife like i'm not interested in this
but yeah um there the museums the museum
is fascinating
but you can definitely there's a
different engine it's funny yusef was
saying like we could
you could spend all day walking around
giza and feel energized by it and just
not tired but then you know in some of
these other spots it's like
the energy just gets drained right out
of you and it's just how you feel like
it's
it's a seat of the pants feeling you can
only experience when you're there
and it's hard to quantify and define and
specifically say
why but undeniably true because i felt
good in those pyramids i felt
really good i felt down i felt good
there these you know the assyrion all
these other places
or especially dendera the dandera
complex temple of hot tour like
i felt good in there in temple of seti
like i was like these places are
magnificent but i'm not it's not just a
visual feeling good like oh
i i'm all inspired by the uh
the massive columns it's something else
about it and people need to experience
it and i've heard it from others but
i experienced it myself while it was not
on top of my head it wasn't like a
placebo thing where it's like okay i
heard you're gonna feel weird in here
because that's not what i heard at all
i was there and i just noticed on my own
that i felt
differently in different places brian
did you experience that when you were
visiting these sites
better at some versus others yeah well
i would say more intrigued
yeah more intrigued with some than
others like the
uh dynastic stuff i i enjoy
i see the you know wonderful
craftsmanship that was involved
uh the capability of the dynasty
egyptians
to be able to do that kind of stuff but
i don't find
them mysterious because like you know i
can see oh
okay so they made this column out of a
number of blocks each
about three feet high you know if you
have six people they could lift it up or
whatever do that but it's the
it's the enigmatic nature of the
of the pre-dynastic megalithic stuff i
remember also
i think only twice so far when we went
to karnak they had
all of karnak was suddenly open because
before that
big areas were were sealed off and i
walked through this one section
there are these giant quartzite seated
in statues
with huge like arms blown off and you
know half the faces missing and stuff
and
that looks like cataclysmic destruction
to me not an invading army
so that um you know it's seeing stuff
like that that just
it you know it's a left brain left brain
right brain thing where the
the two can meld together and like
analyze together so yeah you know this
is so you know i'm getting very excited
to go back now i was
uh i was to go next month and i kind of
thought oh well it doesn't really matter
but now
i'm getting excited to go back and
pretty soon i'll be able to as they say
smell the camels that's
yeah you'll all experience that uh when
you get over there that's for sure
yes and i was going to say in terms of
like the megalithic sites that inspire
wonder and maybe we can make this our
our last topic here but uh you briefly
mentioned it jimmy but the uh the
assyrian
which is this tremendous megalithic
structure that's off to the side of the
the temple of seti the first i think and
uh
just we and we had the chance on our
trip to go down it's another special
permission to go down into the assyrian
but if you want you want a place that
sort of inspires you know wonder and and
just
mystery and has that feeling the
assyrian is just that place it's a trip
like
i i don't know how else to to describe
it but
yeah it's something about that i mean
going down in there and these
70 80 ton single pieces of granite that
have sort of interlocked together
it's very similar to the to the valley
temple at giza but almost
almost larger in some ways uh increa you
know no real
markings no glyphs there's there's some
work that was done on the limestone at
the end
you've got the you know just yeah that
place
i mean i assume you you you're going
back down into there on on your trip in
october too
oh yeah yeah yeah it's good definitely
worth it um
that place is unreal in and thank
goodness
for those uh that couple that we're
doing the 3d mapping of all of
everything they got the precise
measurements
um because i've always heard like oh it
could be this way though it's
approximately these
these huge uh pillars or or stone blocks
are this tall
and we got the exact amounts and like it
was or the precise details of it and
i mean it's when you're standing in
there like i said like when you know
you're in the presence of greatness like
this place was
unreal it was insane and the layout of
itself is very
i don't know what to make of it little
alcoves everywhere
around yeah yeah very strange in fact i
saw on twitter recently some pictures
from uh you know black and white sort of
turn of the century
pictures that that there was a much
lower uh water level that because
today the water level this green
connection then a lot of people don't
realize that the assyrian continues down
quite a way like 30 plus feet down like
11 meters is the figure that i've heard
which is like 35 feet or thereabouts uh
and you i've seen some pictures recently
of the assyrian with a lot of that water
drained out and looking down so
those those blocks continue down into
the ground and one of the reasons that
there is water there is there's also a
tunnel
down there that they've never fully
explored but apparently it connects to
the water table that's why there's water
in there now
and they just don't spend any money
trying to drain it out they they have a
problem draining it out because it keeps
coming in
through this tunnel that's that's
connected down the bottom which is
finally funnily enough also a thing you
have on many
many of these other sites which is you
know the presence of groundwater and
tunnels that go down
into it like same thing as osiris shaft
bottom levels full of water with tunnels
going off on the sides that nobody's
really explored
you know uh hawara where the labyrinth
is
you go down as tunnels that lead down
into the water with shafts that
i mean petri explored back in the day
but god only knows what's under the
ground at hawara
like you said brian we should definitely
do more of these because there's no end
of things to talk about
um endless but yeah the assyrian was one
of my absolute favorite sites and that
was a place that i was looking forward
to getting
into to see to see and yeah you
mentioned johanna james earlier uh
in the in the break jimmy and she's she
was on our trip with us she's been
producing amazing content she did a
great video on the assyrian
that's one of the ones that i've i'm
working on too because i had the chance
to film there as well on that same trip
and um yeah i'm really really looking
forward to digging into that place and
and
putting some more content out about it
because it's fascinating and it goes
further than people think too there's a
there's a long tunnel alcove system at
the end that
that's like 100 meters almost long that
you can you can walk up
um that is covered in hieroglyphs it's
plastered and then covered in
hieroglyphs but that
i don't think anyone that looks at that
place
you can't say it's the same thing as the
temple of seti the first it's almost as
if they
while make while making that temple
discovered that the assyrian was here
in the ground and they turned their
whole the whole temple just a little bit
to the right so they weren't
they could they could go next to it you
know instead of
over it so it's at a whole different
that's a whole different level
than the rest of the dynastic temple
right yeah
all right well right on this was awesome
i want to thank both it's great great
i'm so glad we did it and we need to do
it again and
we all need to go to peru together and
we need to make egypt happen and
when we stop recording i have an idea
about egypt i won't say it on and people
get mad at me because like oh stop
recording go say something off of it but
like just an idea
all i know is that anyone that's
listening to this that has a desire to
go to egypt
you can make it happen you can go there
or peru this year
you have plenty of time that in the
event of worldly issues involving
whether it's getting
a vaccine that you don't want or whether
it's travel restrictions
you have plenty of time to back out of
it and not lose a single thing
so if you have this itching to go
because i saw this on our trip i saw
so many comments afterwards like i was
going to go i wish i had and i didn't i
was too nervous
guys like i'm telling you get busy live
and get off that couch go
you won't regret it and there's
something very liberating about going
when there's risk when there's all these
other people that are staying home
there's something special about it makes
it quite exciting and it's like it
reminds you just how alive you really
are
and and when you get out to see the
sites that people have wanted to see
their entire lives
like i would just encourage anyone to do
it do your research you know there's
always risk for anything but
with without risk there's no reward and
and it makes life so much more fun i
think so
anyone watching this a wants to go you
can go you can make it happen
yeah i i would absolutely agree with
that go with you guys on that trip i'm
i'm also planning a trip to egypt
uh it may be shortly after you're i'm
still look i'm looking at the end of
this year as well i haven't announced or
figured out the specific details for
mine yet
um but yeah go anyone like go with you
guys go
i would same thing i'd encourage people
to to go because it's
and it's also a rare opportunity even
though it's
you know you might perceive some risk
certainly i'm not sure the rest of the
world is always
on board with the same level of risk and
how we're perceiving it but
um you know you you go because there's a
unique opportunity that's
presented at the moment with these sites
and that's the fact that they're
relatively empty of tourists which
really hasn't been the case for the last
40 years in places like egypt
you know there was there's been
tremendous i mean seas of people at
these places and certainly in december
when we were there we had many of them
to ourselves
and i suspect that's going to continue i
mean i'm sure the numbers will slowly
increase this year but i don't think
it's going to take some time to get back
to the you know the full like there's a
there's 50 or 62 buses at this location
you know like
we was incredible we'd pull up to these
we'd pull up to these parking lots that
you could see were designed to take
you know 70 100 tour buses and we're the
only one there and
literally the only one so you know these
now's the time to this year i think is
the time to try and
grab that opportunity uh even if it does
come with some additional
difficulties in trying to arrange travel
it can be done
um yeah i'm i'm i'm my sympathies with
everyone in australia and the people
that that have issues with quarantines
and lockdowns and i know that the
the uk has that as well so hopefully as
we said hopefully that'll that'll
slow down this year and and and some of
these things will open up and more
people have more opportunity to
to get back out there because yeah it's
uh i can tell you for from my personal
experience in 20 you know 2020 man i was
i was in australia in february
early on before this started just got
out before it really kicked off
came back to the states didn't go
anywhere until the trip in
in november december uh to egypt and i
was
ecstatic to get out and to do some
traveling and it it felt amazing you
know i think that's
a lot of people are missing that feeling
at the moment so uh hopefully
yep hopefully you can you can hopefully
this next year will bring
a bit more uh a bit more freedom on that
respect for a lot of people
so yeah i hope so all right well yeah
awesome guys
so thanks again thank you both of you um
great wonderful thank you
and we will definitely do it again
absolutely excellent
all right brian pleasure to make your
acquaintance finally i'll see you in
egypt brother
my honor always great to speak to you
man
yeah you too yeah and uh it's time to
get off
yeah indeed and and stay posted everyone
will probably have an announcement
coming
out pretty soon about south america this
year too you bet we're going to make it
happen
come here sawyer sawyer says hi
everybody
cheers guys cheers